i'm gonna go with steve weintraub
collider
how are you doing today sir good choice
i like the choice steve very good yes
i'm well it's nice to see you nice to
see you um you might not remember this
but it was i guess two years ago when we
spoke and you told me how you were
writing a very personal film
and
obviously it ended with the you know
it's belfast
and i'm curious first of all
congratulations on the movie um
if the pandemic had never happened do
you think this film would have still
happened it's an interesting question i
sometimes ask myself that it certainly
provided a quiet and an introspection
that allowed for the sounds of belfast
to come right into my head but i think
that in any case after 50 years this
sense that what happened on that day
august 15 1969 when i heard that sound
and then i saw those
shapes and then i saw those people
i i've begun to understand over decades
changed my life profoundly and that i
had not adjusted to what that meant and
i needed somehow to go
uh explore it you've been in this
business a long time you know that um
not everything gets amazing reviews
great reviews what has it been like for
you with this film with the such the
strong reception by critics and
audiences well it's fantastic when you
meet people who are from wildly
different parts of the world come up to
you and say that's my story that is the
biggest thrill to be honest because i
wrote from the heart with a very
specific story of a very specific place
that it that it seems to touch people in
that way is amazing and what i love is
that when people do come up to me having
seen the film they don't talk about the
film their opening lines are almost
always about their own childhood somehow
the little explosion of the story has
just ignited things in their own lives
that you can see they want to speak
about and share for me that is an
absolute thrill uh i think you might
remember this about me but i love
talking about the editing process
because it's ultimately where it comes
together can you sort of talk about some
of the challenges you encountered when
you got in the editing room were there
any big obstacles that you had to
overcome biggest obstacle steve was not
having the editor in the room uh oona uh
was in dublin and i was just outside
london but it meant that we both were
like sort of worker ants going through
what in this case to answer your
question was the
detailed excavation of every slither of
jude hill's performance
every glint in the eye in a listening
moment that allowed us to be compelled
by the boy absorbing his situation half
of his performance was always going to
be reacting so the search for the
perfect moments of reaction that are
most alive most present most
concentrated that was where most of my
energies went and
going through i must have gone through
i mean hundreds of hours of news
archival footage from that period in in
the history of northern ireland which
was amazing to do and and the
benefit if you like of of being locked
down to do it was that i had the time to
try and get that right
uh can i ask did you have like a much
longer cut did you end up with a lot of
deleted scenes
i did have a much longer cut i had a
really much longer script to begin with
uh it had a modern buddy it had an older
body it had a return to belfast for the
same character it had music from all
sorts of other places including van
morrison's amazing catalogue
so yes there was really quite a lot that
needed to be refined back down to the
period story
uh framed by
the color of the city but not by older
buddy an original structural inspiration
had been cinema paradisa which you'll
remember starts with a grown-up man who
discovers the the death of the
projectionist back in his hometown he
goes back there and the story unfolds
from there for our story that ended up
not working but yes there was a great
deal that was uh uh sort of
refined down to the essential
i know i'm out of time but can i just
ask will any of that footage ever be
seen or is it tucked away no you will
see some of those deleted scenes on the
home entertainment version um
including that that that return and and
uh and several other scenes that might
surprise you
cool i'm i'm definitely going to watch
thank you so much for your time and
as always great to talk with you good to
talk to you steve nice to see you thank
you
a thor in the background next time not
iron man please
make a note i got it no problem
you